spot-on idea is a set of originally made
out of five Chinese Peranakan vessels I
wanted to find something quite a local
something that many single points could
relate to Chinese peranakan vessels came
the closest is inherently unique to the
three areas in service Asia and
Singapore being one of them so that was
interesting to use it as a basis to
produce this set of looks my motivation
is to give them a new lease of life
giving them a new form of industry in
the petition gives them a new form of
communication about Peranakans about
local culture another hand over to a
certain extent pal modernism has many
Jewish culture and heritage I started
thinking about this project a while ago
I was inspired by partek printing
artists and artisans who use our wax 2
to melt wax and then to apply it on
fabrics because the wax protects the
fabric from colors they dip it into a
pool or die and by doing so when
removing the wax decrease patterns when
I first experiment the ogden on this
technique actually i didn't expect it to
work and what i did was to paste by hand
individual synthetic plastic stickers on
the porcelain west and by sandblasting
it your I'm removing the areas that
previously wasn't covered by the dots
and to expose this white biscuit which I
thought it was quite beautiful when I
was mad that's why and thus you know
when I removed the stickers I expose a
doctor motives of the original glazed so
no I was interesting this contrast of
textures and also of colors the new
nepali West themselves were really
suitable for this technique because they
were full of colors you cannot get a
contrast because the same plaster areas
are essentially why so then you get this
rich contrast of white and color this
effect you see of the traditional
Peranakan motifs being broken down it's
almost like a pixel you know when you
stand far away you can still kind of
make out the Phoenix you know and
flowers and colors and how the patterns
come together but you know when you look
at the piece of porcelain ware close up
it kind of disappears you can see more
of the dots not the contrast between the
white match the pieces and a glossy
surfaces this difference in the dots the
quality of the dots and quality
the negative spaces also kind of talks
about the narrative of how modernism is
being interpreted into culture and
heritage I wanna say is a mixture I got
a synthesis between what loss and what
is and perhaps a lot of future calls for
us I'm pretty much interested in making
objects that communicate so
communicating certain ideas or ideas are
taking a critic on society speaking for
the people and about the people in the
boss society and culture in general
you